Okay,
we'll come back to the grammar of words.
Last time we talked about general concepts morphemes,
Alan Morse,
different types of morphemes including affixes,
roots bound,
morphine's versus free morphine's.
Go ahead and review that material whenever you need it.
In the next few lessons,
we'll look at individual parts of speech.
We'll start with nouns and the basic properties of now.
Now these aren't necessarily properties that belong to announce,
they're just properties that will most likely show up and downs in the languages
that many of you will choose to learn,
but start with the property known as class.
Class allows languages to categorize or group notes.
Class can be based on the form of a noun.
For instance,
in the romance languages,
the nouns ending it's suffix often reveals to announce class nouns that end in
oh in Spanish are masculine,
but nouns that end in our feminine,
even though eloquent domains,
a room and like I said means a house,
so there's not much relation between meaning and gender.
Gender is a category that nouns are grouped into.
There can be some correlation,
for instance,
in Spanish.
Again when I'm okay,
it is feminine and that means a woman and one of them is masculine and that
means a mad.
This holds for Spanish,
other romance languages and the Indo European family.
Generally Chinese on the other hand actually relates the nouns meaning to the
nouns class.
There's a classifier word that comes out when you're counting announced and this
classifier shows the nouns class in Chinese,
so these three words in mandarin mean one cup alcohol or one drink.
The Word Bay there isn't necessarily cup.
It's the classifier for that.
Now in that case we have a language of that marks the announced class more or
less based on its meaning.
Now if you haven't dealt with it before,
class can be a tricky concept to get used to,
particularly because we no longer have known class are now in gender,
in English,
but we do have the next property we'll explore,
which is grammatical number,
grammatical numbers,
a way to count nouns.
In the example I used earlier in the last video dog is the singular.
Now we had the ethics s plural morphine,
which is a bound morphine to form the word dogs.
In that case,
we have a plural noun,
so we see that English has an opposition between singular and plural for nouns.
Other languages might have more numbers.
For instance,
in some forums of ancient Greek,
you had a duel number to represent two instances of anatomy,
so there was a singular bulls which would mean a foot or just foot boulder for
two feet or a pair of feet and pull days for more than a pair of feet,
plural.
The final property we'll discuss here is case.
Case really shows the nouns use in a sentence,
so we'll talk about two basic uses.
The first is a noun as a subject.
When the noun acts as a doer of an action,
it is in the subject or a nominative case.
When announced acts as the object of an action,
it is in the object or accusative case.
Some languages don't distinguish this.
Classical Latin did modern Greek,
Japanese,
and a variety of other languages distinguished this formally.
Take a Latin phrase.
Whoops,
Modem Hubot,
which means the city has a wall.
Wood has a nominative affix,
a case marker telling you that it is the subject.
The city Moodle has an object marker am telling you that it's an object and
accusative case and how that is the verb.
So you know that the city has a wall and not that the wall has a city.
Because in Latin word order doesn't matter as much.
In English,
we show the subject and the object by word order.
In other words,
we placed the subject before the verb and the object after the verb and we avoid
these case affixes.
Okay.
We now end up with three basic properties of nouns,
case number in class,
we can differentiate forms of nouns and languages,
especially in fusional or gluten,
Advil,
languages that we'll mark these properties and if we differentiate all these
forms and we laid them out in a chart,
we can come up with the entire declension of a.
Now,
sometimes this will be very basic.
Sometimes this will be very complex in a language like Latin or ancient Greek or
Russian or Turkish.
You have a variety of noun forms in other languages like Chinese or Hawaiian.
We don't really talk about the declension of unowned because the noun has one
basic form and that applies everywhere.
I hope this video has been helpful and please join me next time when we will
talk about how verbs work.